what's happening reject nation we're
gonna watch episode eight of all of us
are dead
leave a like if you can doesn't take
much work also uh thanks to everyone
who's joined our patreon page full
length watch alongs for all of us are
dead are over there along with a bunch
of other shows that we covered too and
the boys are prepper thanks for helping
us down these highlights let's get to it
[Music]
what's your plan
[Music]
oh my
fire starter
it's like fighting the terminator
you you are awful dick just gonna take
this one kid's word for it
you mean he can confirm that
all
the students are zombies yeah from up
here
isolated what a crock of [ __ ] that is so
annoying
wow
wow
no zombie off
no she is the secret weapon
we on fire
up in here
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh god
hey
[ __ ] you i'm so mad at that guy yeah and
he's gonna live all the way to the end i
just know it
[Applause]
she
that's gross
glad things are optimistic for her
she's your secret weapon yeah see how
much she helped out just now
[Music]
it's a great team-building exercise
that's a really good sos yeah guys now
is not the time for perfectionism
pick up supplies
[Laughter]
foreign
no way came back with a bus
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
windshield wipers find something to hold
onto
hurry up come on man
let me check
[Music]
[Applause]
this episode should be called apocalypse
problem solving
maybe namra has firebread
now she's gonna think she got bullied by
you guys
no yeah that guy totally roasted her in
a livestream
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
foreign
you guys are a god damn embarrassment
take
m
[Music]
oh that one was a cupid arrow right into
her heart
[Music]
white blood cells are killing it
[Music]
we haven't seen her since she ran out
well at least she feels bad about it
i thought you wouldn't be locked
up
you'll be number one
[Applause]
um
um
oh
i swear to god if you push miss park
[Applause]
son of a [ __ ]
foreign
[Music]
man she fortunately stored you in the
right room yeah helping out to the very
end
how are you gonna make it to the roof
yeah without running into guinom
um
yeah now you're invincible too you have
the best experience thank god you came
here
ah i saw the shadow man
[Laughter]
oh
damn
um
oh
[Laughter]
oh
don't jump off the roof
i just want the whole school to burn
[Music]
did he not puke her up
i hope you guys notice him
this is not going according to plan
oh
she probably never thought it was even
possible
do you hear that
i hope you hear that
he's right behind you
oh
samantha is
[Music]
damn it
oh uh freaking
god i'm trying to behave like one of
those marvel netflix shows
soon to be no longer netflix [ __ ] take
it away john that was a very emotional
episode and i really appreciated the
interplay
that they did because you know not every
episode has a certain amount of zombie
carnage i feel like this one is maybe a
little more slight in that department
what i really enjoyed that they employed
and making up for that was a really
tight interplay between very touching
moments
that would then segue
often in the same scene to very sinister
unsettling tones and they would weave in
and out of that i thought very nicely
and uh you know we cut outside the
school maybe once or twice but i thought
you know just
again we've done so much sort of bonding
with the students up until now you know
like we pretty much know our core group
here
uh but this episode i thought brought
more sort of layers out and brought a
nice sense of
levity to the circumstances while also
being in a situation that is especially
hopeless because you know like the
chopper leaves the guy takes off he
doesn't bother to help them at all he
commits to leaving them there
uh and yeah this as we ramp up towards
the end of the season felt like a sort
of
i'm not sure it felt like a calm before
some type of storm although you know as
the situation expands and it seems like
the governor or this military gains more
control i'm not even really sure
what to expect in terms of how
you know the last several episodes last
three or four episodes of the season
will play out but i thought this was
really interesting one tonally
speaking i did some nice little zoom ins
on different characters again
that was kind of my main takeaway from
this episode
obviously you know
bringing out some of the love
especially between chong son and anjo
it's about time
but uh what were your feelings how did
you how did you like it
i liked parts of it uh this is your
least favorite episode of the season i'd
say so okay fair enough
yeah i know some of you guys tend to
come in our comments and say
like yo you you guys are reactors who
really
get this episode get these episodes a
lot
and i appreciate those comments but i
got to be honest when i'm not
huge on something okay i i the the first
10 minutes kind of upset me a lot and
they they kind of pulled me out of the
episode just a little too much
it felt like plot convenience to keep
them trapped here
and i wasn't a fan of how that
went down
like you send people there you send that
you send choppers there to a it's a big
ass school yeah you know and you you've
seen moments where they're like these
swat teams are going in
to buildings yeah and you know shooting
their way through malls and stuff
and
then you send them in and granted
they're not as big of a of like a of a
soldier unit to to go in there and
shoot down some zombies or whatever
but they're there for like five seconds
take one kid's word for it who's trapped
on the roof and then they just take off
and of course like oh this they happened
to just get the door open because
someone else in the school happened to
set a fire
so they said they happened to trigger
the door open because they just happened
to see
and to see the chopper take off and no
one notices the kids on the roof
and uh i it really cut it was the first
time this show pulled me out
and felt like they wrote themselves into
a situation
to keep them on the to keep them at the
school
and
it's like do i really want them to leave
the school no i don't but
uh it was i found myself actually
annoyed with a choice
so i do
i like i don't mind it but it was the
first time where i felt like an episodic
installment in an episode where there
were some things that felt like very
necessary to me but then
the i the way i used to feel before
where i thought things were kind of
seamlessly
intertwined between zombie stuff
tension and then drama
uh
and i i felt like they wrote themselves
into a situation this this reminded me
most of the walking dead i was waiting
for being totally honest
yeah it does it has like let's
drastically slow down over some
convenience to keep our characters
trapped here yeah
and then now let's just have a bunch of
conversations which are all
fine like that's all it all enhances
character development for
many of them like i'm like sitting there
going i don't know most of these kids
truly you know it's like i i know them
through the situations and their
personalities but
you know to get the some of the crushes
out of the way just yeah i i just i just
found myself starting to nitpick and
i'll i'll call it a nitpick because i i
did find myself kind of going down that
rabbit hole in nitpicking
like when they're trying to start a fire
but she has a fight like a
a lighter there the whole time like okay
was
what was the point of all this and you
could just hand them the ladder you know
what they're trying to do with it and
like it's just supposed to be some deep
character thing because she was shy
of presenting a lighter because that's
an indicator of her lack of perfection
of the perception that people have of
her and she doesn't trust people or have
friends and this is her giving herself
like is it supposed to be her like
part of her arching to feeling like she
has for is that what it's supposed to be
maybe
i'm sure someone's gonna tell me all of
that
uh but that's just another thing where
i'm like nah i feel like you just i
start feeling like they're just
writing themselves i never felt like
anything was being dragged out and this
was the first time i felt like something
was being a little this this is being a
bit dragged out
and uh
it was
it's like i i don't mind it
like there's like whoa okay what do i
like so we gotta see what happened in
this park and
how
it
i do do you remember her name i remember
her name the girl and uh oh and the food
club uh closet nyon
now young nyon yeah okay now young all
right
but now young we we didn't we never saw
that scene unfold before
so i like seeing now yawn
well
that's again i made fun of this before
in the last time when they were doing
all the cameras when they were talking
to the camera or when she was trapped in
there like
every single time she wants to go out
there
like and then hope someone just brings
up what happened yeah
someone else she wants to go out there
so bring someone then let me pack stuff
i'm gonna try to give it to someone
brings up what
happened and it's it started
feeling
less
was this the one that talked about am i
thinking of something else or that
talked about the get it giving into the
poetic nature is that a different show
i'm thinking of where did this episode
do that i think it was a different i
think i think i have a different show
i'm not sure i must be thinking of a
different show tied up poetry
uh yeah i think there uh like i like i
like seeing that and it made me
appreciate her character a little bit
more yeah um
i don't feel bad for her still at all
and uh i i i don't because i'm like
while miss park is being
misunderstanding because
she takes on some of the guilt of
feeling like she cornered her into doing
something like that
i don't care how scared you are
to get to the point where you straight
up kill someone because your
feelings are hurt or embarrassed or
something i mean you and you still did
it for a pretty even if that was a play
you still
did it with a petty a good amount of
prejudice and and hatred in your heart
too yeah so i don't give a
i can't feel bad i don't feel bad for
her
i really don't no matter how much he
cries or we try to give some type of
sympathetic lens towards her
i appreciate the duo
i don't necessarily feel bad for her but
i i appreciate that they're at least
bothering me
i like that i appreciate the nuances too
like i i enjoyed seeing her more
and i enjoyed seeing the the flashbacks
more
and uh i like the fact that she does
feel haunted by her actions yeah and
it's not to say you can't come around to
a character like we didn't see her
devolve into
what guinom is or if she's just a
regular zombie we haven't seen that it
looks like he pretty much devoured her
i don't know it seems like even if
probably she was
you would assume that then she would
turn into like what namra has become but
then i'm like i don't know if there's
going to be enough of her left and it's
funny because they establish they rap
and heal
they they do but the question is we
never see her remains and the way they
play that scene is so bloody that uh you
know like the other guy i guess came
back as a normal zombie right the guy
that yunji was eating in the
uh lab that she like puked up that guy
he came back as like an actual regular
zombie i think in this episode so maybe
what was worse about how guinom
like we know when he was being bit he
was being like devoured by like eight
zombies
yeah yeah but i'm saying like that when
yeah i don't know i mean i don't know
what the key is between regular zombies
biting you and then you mutating into
that but it seems like you know guinon
bites
he gets the new advanced virus
and then you
that's like this is the first trackable
new virus bite and then you get the
thing with yunji and the other teacher
and that guy seemed to have just turned
into a normal zombie so i don't really
what to expect with nyon although
i mean you don't see it and i feel like
you know nowadays especially everything
can be hidden off camera for a surprise
later but i don't know just the way they
played that really made it feel like i
don't know if there's going to be much
left of her to heal
and also he didn't puke her up so i
don't know i'm
questioning the rules right now
that's a fair question
yeah i uh that was that was cool death
i i like the detective a lot being
trapped with the influencer
and uh it like the the the argument fun
banter they have and they
have and then the fact that the guy
comes back with a bus which i think is
more convenient
and i love the convenient i love the
i love the coincidental bumping into uh
oonji
when she's on the bike yeah i thought
that came into the fold really well yeah
and
it got out of anything in this episode
that got me most excited it's the
cliffhanger
and also that
tease of what's to come
and i did like that chong son finally
revealed how he feels
which is just another indicator that
he's going to turn
i think i think he's going to die i've
said it for the past few episodes but i
think it's i feel like he's going to die
okay or
or morph or yeah i get turned into i
think he's going to turn to an actual
zombie i don't think he's going to turn
into like one of these super zombies
yeah yeah um so yeah you know it's like
i i guess i just didn't feel much for
this i wasn't like sitting here livid
the time i was genuinely annoyed
was the first 10 minutes
um but i wasn't sitting here like
really
upset or
bored for even that matter
uh it just uh this was the most
there's the least affected i would say
like even the nothing was really the
final moments were intense
but a lot of it really wasn't that tense
to me
nor was the drama really moving me
to put it
simply i was just like
okay
i'm watching watching some stuff happen
it's kind of interesting yeah that's
just my overall
vibe with it i don't i feel like it's
out of all the episodes
as a complete package
per episode this is
the least interesting
one to me with some very
isolated intro
incredibly interesting moments
yeah i mean i i guess i i probably maybe
was more sucked into this particular one
overall but i i think i would agree i
mean of all of them this one feels the
least plugged into the overall momentum
that is driving just the entire
situation connected across all these
different places and i mean you do check
in with your the detective and with uh
firefighter dad like you you check out
of the school a couple times but you're
mostly there and yeah i mean in the
first i thought the fire thing that's
probably the most frustrating detail to
me because
that really did feel just like a plot
device because like the sprinklers come
on it makes sense but at the same time i
thought that was going to be a new
problem to create way bigger tension
whereas
it does just seem like a plot mechanic
to you know create a certain type of
outcome to get young g out of school to
get you know the door open blah blah
and yeah it's like as much as i expected
them not to be saved by the helicopter
there is
some of that where you're like they
still could have been though
uh so yeah
i don't who's that guy who was
really has feelings for omg
i think he is so underwritten
that i just
don't like him uh to the point where i
don't even fully get his choice
be uh to to just completely
lie
and say like yeah there's no one trying
to get through this door right now or
like he's such a coward like he is
he's he's like beyond cowardly to the
point where i'm like i know people like
that exist don't get me wrong
i get that but i i know nothing more
than that about him yeah it's like you
have the echoing remnants of the i guess
they should all die like when he's
talking to her in the early episodes
where it's like they should all burn
they should that's not even his belief
and it's not even his belief yeah it
just feels like kind of the last idea
that he was left with and i guess he's
not going to make any decisions beyond
that is how it feels like yeah i guess
he's just kind of resigned to that
which doesn't feel like
the strongest choice because we don't
really get to see inside of him yeah the
only good thing that he's done
is he's helped prevent oonji from
jumping off of the roof yeah
that was about it uh
but when it came to when she was being
you know
sexually assaulted in the first episode
he didn't stand up for her and he took
the video himself
yeah
but he at least like bargained
like he at least threw a little bit of a
pair of balls to bargain
with the one guy about like hey can i
what was the deal something about the
phone right like he had some deal there
oh yeah yeah
that the video wouldn't go live if they
did something or other yeah yeah so he
at least
fought in that sense yeah he found her
on the roof to try to stop her
so this guy has the ability to speak up
he has the ability to
think for himself
um but yeah he's he's so cowardly
and i don't know much i don't know
anything about him other than the fact
that he's he's just such a coward and so
i don't have a
understanding to
why so i just get left with a feeling of
i kind of hate you okay like you you
just leave omg behind when she's like i
mean she's like so bullied like she's
she's more she's just more bullied yeah
she's it's worse than i
originally thought like when you're
doing all those flashbacks like oh man
like they're they they were just like
dog filing on her yeah uh like every
possible opportunity it looks like yeah
so every choice she makes i completely
get and i kind of root for her and the
rage just seethes off of her yeah yeah
and i get it like her wanting to go in
and burn the school i'm like [ __ ] it
yeah go for it like
i forget about the other people in
school the time because i go yeah i get
where you're coming from
uh but then that friend of hers just
abandoned her and when she wanted to go
and try to retrieve the phone he was too
cowardly to go yeah
and then um
and then uh he's he straight up lets
these people that's like a form of
murder obviously
you don't pull the lever you're you're
complicit
so uh
yeah i think um
yeah it was just very frustrating and
maybe they had to keep them pretty for a
show that seems to go out of their way
to kind of give you depth to like every
character and that isn't very
underwritten yeah and a show that isn't
afraid to do that with just one
character isolated alone
yeah you know is why i'm surprised we
didn't get anything with
him
he's just a black hole of of ineffectual
cowardices
i like what they're doing with nomrom
that's her neighbor yeah
uh i like what they're doing with namra
i i think that's really
really
good i get this vibe she'll be like the
last one standing probably
as long as they don't go to superhero
with it because i mean that is a pretty
great ability for her to just be able to
kind of step in with super strength and
well she seems to have more senses at
least know how to
hone in on them better than the other
than the other two yeah she does seem
like she can activate her in hearing
sense really well yeah auditory senses
so
yeah i mean it's not it wasn't a bad
episode but but uh it was just the least
compelling one i would say it's the most
walking daddy episode it really it
really was i started like oh [ __ ] it's
feeling like walking dead
if you know you know you know
yeah
but hey next next week we're gonna have
a show or next episode we're gonna have
a showdown greenup so
yeah that'll be good
it's like when it came to the archers
too you know it was like
the story of
all i know how to do is archery it's all
i care about i'm like you know and from
what the show showed me that's all you
do too
it's been perfect visual representation
up till now it would be nice to have
details beyond
why you are the way you are yeah
yeah it's like the start of something
but it's like go a little deeper on that
because that's already what you've shown
me like if you're gonna slow down to
give substance or more nuance i think
you can't just completely mess with the
pace
that's fair you know i know a lot of
people probably think this episode's
phenomenal and uh cute yeah i'm glad you
like it
i just want cool chicken archery girl to
get together by the end
that's what i'm hoping for right now
hopefully yeah all right guys well
thanks for being here
and uh let's do a page
pandemic jones who better to shout out
in the midst of a real life pandemic
watching a show about a zombie pandemic
i feel like you would be a great person
to have in the survivor group because
you have such a lively upbeat spirit i
feel like you would be the one to sing
us a song or something like that to keep
our spirits lifted and to keep us from
slipping into bleak resign for our lives
to end i feel like you would be
responsible for making sure we make it
to the end and hey maybe you'll have to
sacrifice yourself selflessly
but it's in your name you know you are
the spirit of the pandemic and you keep
us lively so brother i hope you're doing
well i hope it's been a good 2022 so far
and we'll catch you next month for
something cheerier
much love
be well
you know him that well i know pandemic
jones so well dude
his name's paul
[Music]